hello someone in Samuel Leeds I'm a
property investor and I teach people how
to invest their money strategically in
property to get the highest return as
possible and in this video I wanted to
give some advice to people who have
inherited money and I get people reach
out to me not all the time but from time
to time they say that they've just
inherited some money from their parents
or from their grandparents what should
they do with it and sometimes it's a
large amount of money and I've met
people as young as 18 years old that
have suddenly inherited hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of pounds and it
can become really quite a weighty
responsibility to know what to do and
I've met people as well who've inherited
a lot of money but they didn't speak to
me and it's six months down the line and
now I've made the wrong decisions so I
just wanted to do a video so hopefully
it will help anybody who is in that
situation so there's four things that
you absolutely should not do with money
that you've inherited or even saved this
could be applicable for you if you've
managed to save up a large amount of
money or maybe you've just been given a
redundancy package but if you've
suddenly got a big amount of money
maybe you've won the lottery who knows
there's four things that you really
shouldn't do and then there's four
things that you really should do and I'm
going to go through what not to do first
and then what you should be doing please
do smash the like button subscribe to
this YouTube channel if you're not
already subscribed turn the notification
bell on when you subscribe as well so
you don't miss a video and if you've got
some thoughts questions ideas comments
comment them below in the below section
so why is it so important that you don't
do these four things when you inherit
money when you get every done a
redundancy payout or where you win the
lottery if you don't prepare yourself
you are going to lose the money it's
gonna go fast and I know this because
statistically most lottery winners end
up poorer after ten years than they were
when they won the lottery so it's really
really really important that you don't
do these four things number one is that
you don't just spend the money you don't
waste the money so when you first get
the money it's really tempting to say
well I've got 300 thousand pounds
what's fifty thousand on a car
I'll still have X amount or just don't a
holiday I just treat myself a little bit
but only a little bit but what happens
is very quickly when you start doing
that it goes it's amazing how fast you
can spend a few hundred thousand pounds
I mean I've spent tens and tens of
thousands of pounds within a week just
throwing the holiday times it can happen
so when you suddenly get it same as
footballers they suddenly get money and
then they just blow it Mike Tyson who I
do respect a lot in many ways but he
when he was making millions of pounds in
boxing he was broke he was almost
bankrupt in debt and that's because he
just spent the money so first thing is
don't spend the money next don't rush to
invest it now what I don't think that
you should not invest it don't rush to
invest it the money's not going to
disappear suddenly overnight unless you
spend it so don't like just buy buy the
next property that comes along or the
next person that comes to you with an
idea or a property or a project or a
joint venture agreement or a scheme
don't just be like okay and put it
straight into it because it looks good
that's the next thing because you're
gonna have a lot of people pitching you
different ideas and saying this is a
really good idea this is a good
initiative this is a project this is a
business I've got this app idea and
you're like well I got the money but
don't do that don't rush to invest it
and number three is don't tell everybody
that you've got the money because if you
do that if you start putting on Facebook
going on all the different Facebook
groups I've got five hundred thousand
pounds but I just inherited last week
and I'm thinking wondering what to do
with it any ideas what's gonna happen is
you're gonna have every single Tom Dick
Harry crawling out the Woodworks to
pitch them on their idea so it's
probably not the best thing that you
tell the world that you've got the money
and then number four is how do I say
this nicely
don't be naive don't be a sucker now if
you've got a lot of money from
redundancy lottery inheritance whatever
you've suddenly
across a lot of money and you're not
experienced in business it's very easy
to have people pull the wool over your
eyes tell you no tell you about the next
big scheme and honestly there are people
out there that I've got schemes which
are legitimate and there are people out
there that have got schemes that are not
legitimate and here's the really
interesting thing when I say don't be a
sucker I'm not talking about scam
artists coming for you may be that I'm
talking as well about IFAs independent
financial advisors pulling the wool over
your eyes and saying to you you know you
need to do this with your money and you
need to do that and this is safe and
lock it here and lock it there when
they're on a commission and everyone's
got an agenda and it's easy when you're
not educated about money to just think
oh I'll just find someone and I'll just
trust them and I'll let them just deal
with it I'm not very good with finance
I'll just let them sort it out I'll just
give it to my mom and she can invest it
I'll just give it to someone I'll just
trust the IFA I just just don't do that
don't be a sucker don't be a fool don't
have anyone pull the wool over your eyes
they're the four things not to do so
don't just spend it don't rush to invest
it there's no urgency it's okay
don't tell everybody on social media how
much you've gotten how much you're
looking to invest because you're just
going to create people calling out the
Woodworks and the before is don't be
naive or be a sucker and just trust
anybody without knowing what's what
yourself okay they're the four things
what not to do the four things that you
should do the four things that I would
encourage that you do number one store
the money away now I say store it away
and not lock it away and there's a big
difference if you've slowly inherited
five hundred thousand pounds what half a
million don't lock it away locking it
away would be you know get putting it
into some scheme where you can't get it
back for five years locking it into some
account you can't touch giving it to
some IFA and letting them don't do that
because if you lock it away and then you
come across a really good opportunity
where you really
I already need it it's locked away what
you wanna do is you want to store it
away there's a difference between
locking and storing but I'll give you
I'll give you a real practical example
when you get your food shopping and
you've got all your different food and
you snacks and whatever you don't just
leave it all on the table in front of
you all the time because then what's
gonna happen you're gonna pick out
you're gonna eat it you're gonna just be
eating it all day but at the same time
you don't lock it in a safe because
you're like I can't trust myself and
lock it in a safe because then what
happens then you're hungry you really
need to eat but you've locked it away
and you can't get to it and you've lost
the key what you want to do is you want
to just be a normal person and put it in
the cupboard put it away and store it in
the cupboard for when you need it in the
same way if you just inherit a load of
money suddenly store it away put it in a
separate bank account that you can't
necessarily see if you don't trust
yourself just put it in an account you
can't see but you could get to if you
really needed to you could go to the
bank and you could get that money that's
called storing your way not locking it
away not having it in your current
account way was just gonna disappear but
store it away first thing really
important store it away number two once
you've stored it away start looking at
investments start looking at properties
now I've said this to so many people
that I've got a lot of money I've said
this to footballers I've said this to
people but I've inherited I've said
listen
don't invest in the very first
opportunity that comes along but start
looking at opportunities start viewing
properties start talking with people but
don't do don't do the first deal you say
the first property you see the estate
agent says it's a great deal isn't it
and you go yeah you're trying to check
no don't do that but just start viewing
properties that it's the sound listen if
you want to if you want to get into a
relationship with somebody okay you what
you're singling you think you know I
want to start dating someone you
shouldn't just go out with the very
first person that used to speak to you
well you see you know you want it you
want to kind of look see what's around
check out your options start talking to
people right maybe that was a bad
example but in the same in business got
a lot of money you want to start seeing
what
around seeing opportunities if you just
buy the first property that you see
sounds good to me
then what's going to happen probably in
about two months time you're going to be
like our man there's so many more
opportunities that are better than that
one so don't buy the first thing that
comes your way but start looking number
three is don't tell the world don't stop
talking on Facebook but do speak to a
few chosen people speak to a few chosen
people that you trust that you respect
that have a track proven record and
investing so many people are gonna have
that give you bad advice and if you're
not in the circle of investors and if
you've not become successful in property
already and you've not you know not if
you're a millionaire normally you've had
to you've had to do a lot of stuff to
become a millionaire and the person that
you've become in getting the million
pounds has made you really smart really
wise really good really shrewd if you
inherit a million pounds you've got the
money but you've not got the the
experience and the knowledge that most
millionaires have so you can disappear
real fast so speak to a few people but
be careful who you speak to speak to
people that you know what their agenda
is as well everyone's got to be clear
about their agenda if you're speaking to
someone that's trying to sell you a deal
but they're on commission but they don't
tell you and it's all shift day no good
speak to a few people but don't be
publicized and get everywhere on
Facebook and number four lastly so
important get educated get smart if
you've got half a million pounds like
you should be putting at least a couple
percent of that money I mean when you
buy a property you'll pay a few percent
stamp duty you'll pay you know you if
you buy a deal from a from a properties
also you might pay them a two percent
finder's fee you pay a state agent your
face solicitors you pay Stan GE tax you
want you're always a little slice that
you pay people when you buy property
deals what I would say is before you buy
anything pay a little bit towards
actually getting educated pay a little
bit and people so Samuel you just say
that because you educate people and
you're trying to get people's money
listen don't I don't care if you do it
with me or not yes I do have property
training programs where I teach people
about how to invest don't do it with me
if you don't want to do it with me but
just get the education from some
because I've met people that have had
hundreds of thousands of pounds and
they've contacted me and I've not seen
the message or I've responded but
they've have not really educated
themself they've not got any mentors
they've not got any proper training and
then what happens is a year later on I
check in with them and uh yeah and they
don't want to talk to me and the reason
they don't want to talk to me is because
it didn't go too well
they've squandered the money they put it
into some investment deal that's now
that they've lost it and that can happen
so if they just spend there just with
that five hundred thousand pounds even
if it had just spent 1% 1% of the money
which is what five grand said it just
put five grand into themselves that have
then had four hundred and ninety five
thousand pounds what's going to go
further five hundred thousand pounds
with a complete non educated person when
it comes to finance some property or
who's gonna win that person with 500
grand or the person that spent five
grand on themself really smart got it
and got four hundred and ninety five
grand I tell you is gonna win hands down
every day of the week the person has
only got four nine five they've spent
five grand on themselves that's just a
fact
and that's why as someone that's given
guidance and my opinion and my
experience on YouTube I would be sinning
against you if I didn't say put some of
that money to yourself even if it's not
with me even if it's of another training
company I don't mind but just get
educated so if you do those four things
instead of the other four things get
educated don't buy the first property
that comes don't rush look at a few key
options open don't publicize it but
speak to a few chosen people and store
the money away so you don't touch it but
you can touch it when you need to invest
it that would be my advice if you need
to if you have an inheritance you've
suddenly come across a little money or
if you've just got a bunch of savings if
you've saved up really hard you're like
I've got loads of savings or you've
suddenly realized I've got equity in my
home I could refinance and get a lot of
money well do it but just follow this
advice and guidance I hope you enjoyed
this video
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below please do smash the like
button and I look forward to seeing you
in the next video thanks so much see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]